[Musica]
greco si perchè perchè me ne sono
occupato ultimamente e me ne sono
occupato fin da ragazzo e e poi il tema
era giusto perché remare si fa fin dai
tempi di omero almeno per quanto la
letteratura ci racconta poi sappiamo
ovviamente di imbarcazioni anche
precedenti quindi ho preso da davvero
alla lettera questo questo sottotitolo
di ted e hicks e ho cominciato a
guardare dentro l'odissea cercando remi
interessanti
allora non si fa che remare in questo
poema lo sapete
odisseo detto latinamente ulisse deve
tornarsene a casa gli inceppi sono tanti
le mete si moltiplicano e di meta in
meta bisogna remare remare significa
spostarsi pre mare significa anche
superare grandi difficoltà ci sono
famosi episodi ne cito due quello di
delle sirene dove a un certo punto si
mette veramente male e quindi omero ci
racconta che si rema veloce bisogna
superare appunto il pericolo c'è un
remare famosissimo quando si
approssimano a scilla e cariddi e lì la
parola remo parola remi torna più volte
insomma il remo è un personaggio dello
disse ah forse nelle immagini ecco che
si proiettano adesso vedete proprio un
antico vaso lo stavano del british y che
fa vedere odisseo legato all'albero
della nave della barca e i rematori ho
scelto qualche altra immagine che magari
vedrete vedrete anche un po di greco non
per spaventare nessuno che non lo
conosca un pochino ma solo per farvi
gioire anche solo visivamente dalla
bellezza di questa scrittura diversa
dalla nostra
dicevo è un personaggio è un personaggio
che che determina tutta la vicenda ma
pensiamo anche al poema intero
all'odissea davvero come a un oceano
attraversato da remy cioè dove proprio
il re mare e l'azione stessa del poeta
l'azione dei versi ogni verso una remata
quindi re mi hanno anche quasi un direi
più che quasi hanno certamente anche una
valenza simbolica metaforica cioè il
processo del ritmo del canto del
racconto questo è un canto è la poesia
antica aveva un ritmo cantato appunto e
quindi il ritmo del re mezzo che re
mezzo dei marinai e anche l'azione del
poeta che ma lo fa avanzare lo sposta
diversoinverso di episodio in episodio
se volete è una metafora che a lunga
vita nella nostra ferratura anche dante
per la divina commedia paragonerà il il
suo viaggio davvero ma a una traversata
marina una lunga traversata ariosto alla
fine del poema orlando furioso ci dirà
che anche lui riporta la nave in porto
quindi l'odissea non solo ci fa vedere
una traversata reale quella di un
personaggio che deve tornare a casa dopo
tanti anni di lontananza che deve
passare di isola in isola di avventura
in avventura remando ma ci mette davanti
anche l'esempio di una di un re mare che
è un raccontare ma un raccontare
ordinato scandito cadenzato cioè nasce
davvero un grande archetipo che poi
resterà con noi si smarriva magari ma è
bello oggi poter ricordare proprio qui
vasto che tra l'altro vanta origini
greche e è proprio in tempi di ri
partenza noi
ci stiamo un po allontanando dalle
sirene dalle sirene del covip dalle
sirene di di tentazioni sbagliate
eccetera eccetera e quindi ho voluto
prendere veramente alla lettera questo
compito però ci sono due remi di cui
voglio parlarvi in particolare dell
odissea che si distinguono per una
particolare capacità figurativa una
particolare capacità simbolica e
metaforica sono remi che non fanno più
quello che un remo deve fare cioè non
remano hanno smesso di fungere sono remi
defunti sono remi defunzionalizzati li
troviamo
nell'undicesimo libro dello disse a
chissà un pochino come fatta l'odissea
che è divisa in 24 canti forse ricorderà
che l'undicesimo libro o canto insomma
comunque poi mi antichi parliamo di
libri l'undicesimo libro è quello in cui
odisseo arriva nel regno dei morti
arriva nella de è un luogo geografico
che si raggiunse raggiunge ovviamente
con una certa fatica odisseo ci arriva
perché circe gli ha dato qualche
indicazione
e qui odisseo incontra un compagno un
suo compagno 1 del suo re mezzo diciamo
del suo equipaggio
il quale si chiama è il peggiore perché
il pen ore non è con loro è il peggiore
si era ubriacato a casa di circe era
andato a cercare un po di frescura
notturna sul tetto della casa
quando poi odisseo ai compagni ripartono
la mattina dopo lui si è ormai liberato
dalla sbronza ma ha dimenticato di
essere su un tetto quindi si precipita
verso la nave e cade si spezza il collo
e la sua anima immediatamente fugge
nella de odisseo arriva nella de e trova
appunto che è il peggiore è già lì ad
attenderlo il pen ore
che la prima anima che lo incontra che
odisseo incontra gli dice vi chiede di
dargli sepoltura per gli antichi era
importantissima la sepoltura del
cadavere se il cadavere non veniva
sepolto o anche solo simbolicamente era
l'anima era destinata un'infelicità ben
superiore a quella che oltretomba pagano
comunque riservava alle anime e che cosa
dice il peggiore audizio gli dice torna
a cercare il mio corpo
mettici sopra un tumulo e sopra il
tumulo metti il mio remo mette il mio
remo il remo con cui ore mavo in mezzo
ai compagni
questo è il primo remo che non fa più il
remo ma fa un simbolo funerario se
vogliamo ma lascia un po da parte il
fatto che si tratti di una tomba
poi vediamo invece come interpretarlo
più costruttivamente più vitalmente
altro remo sempre nell'undicesimo libro
dello disse a odisseo incontra lo
spirito di tiresia e fondamentalmente
odisseo e lì per incontrare tiresia
tiresia un profeta quindi ha il dono
della preveggenza e gli deve dire che
cosa lo aspetta tiresia dunque gli dice
che tornerà a casa che trionferà su i
pretendenti farà strage ma che la sua
storia non finisce lì perché lui dovrà
ripartire e perché odisseo dovrà
ripartire noi leggiamo che l'odissea
finisce con il ritorno a casa con la
strage ovviamente ma da tiresia sappiamo
che ci sarà un seguito che l'odissea non
racconta ed è la ripartenza di odisseo
per respirare la strage odisseo deve
partire andare molto lontano finché non
incontri uomini che non hanno conoscenza
del mare che non hanno conoscenza dunque
del sale che non conoscono i remi
odisseo se ne andrà lì con il suo remo
in spalla e
i primi a incontrarlo gli chiederanno
perché giri con un ventilabro il
ventilabro quel quell'oggetto che separa
la pula dai chicchi del grano quindi il
remo viene scambiato per quello che non
viene scambiato per un oggetto
diversissimo qui odisseo avrà capirà che
la sua espiazione compiuta e l'ipo
trapiantare il remo secondo me è
evidente la somiglianza trarremo che
odisseo pianterà eremo che il pen ora e
gli chiede di piantare sono due reni che
significano una chiusura il compiersi di
un destino ma quello che a me interessa
non solo come amante del greco ma come
amante delle lingue della letteratura
perché questo io faccio il mestiere
scrivo e insegna letteratura in un
università all'estero anch'io sono a
oxford quello che mi interessa è quello
che omero della vita del di un oggetto
ma anche della vita della lingua
c'è qui noi assistiamo a un oggetto c'è
un remo che non è più un remo ma diventa
qualcos'altro diventa appunto l'immagine
il simbolo di un destino compiuto quello
quello di alpe neuer è morto e sepolto è
quello di odisseo finalmente pacificato
con con tutti i suoi con tutte le sue
vittime con tutti i pretendenti che lo
hanno che lo hanno insidiato che hanno
gli hanno portato via i suoi averi
ecco omero ci fa vedere come nasce una
metafora
ed è questo quello che ci interessa
allora forse dietro ogni metafora ogni
immagine figurata ogni simbolo in poesia
in letteratura ma anche nelle nostre
vite quotidiane dove in effetti un po di
letteratura c'è sempre anche se
difficile riconoscerla
a volte siamo poeti senza rendercene
conto questo però la scrittura la fa lo
fa meglio dell'orale perché c'è più
studio perché cè più intenzione perché
c'è più forma
ecco diciamo dietro ogni metafora forse
si cela il compiersi di un destino
lì era il destino del pen ora il destino
di odisseo allora io non mi voglio
lasciare con un'immagine funebre tutto
il contrario
vi voglio dire appunto che anche noi
dobbiamo insomma guardare a tutti i
nostri alpe nori a tutti quelli che
reclamano qualcosa da noi perché il loro
destino si compia perché li possiamo
accompagnare alla loro alla loro così
maturità maturazione ultima nella vita
nel senso della loro vita è così
dobbiamo fare come odisseo che dobbiamo
far pace con con i nostri nemici o con
le contraddizioni che che ci circondano
per chiudere questi fogli sono
semplicemente qui con me perché io vi
possa leggere i due i due passi dello
disse ai minuti ci sono ancora sono
perfettamente in tempo quello proprio in
cui è il peggiore che poi farà da
modello al palinuro di virgilio che poi
ritornerà nel purgatorio di dante sono
davvero questi versi pieni di futuro
pieni di futuro anche per questo ve li
voglio leggere perché a quello noi
miriamo però il futuro a una sua
antichità e questo io mi impegno
continuamente a raccontare nei miei
libri e nella mia insomma vita di
professore universitario
e il pen ore gli parla questa è una mia
traduzione la poi signore si sta
rivolgendo a odisseo ti prego di
ricordarti di me in compianto insepolto
non lasciarmi indietro
partendo union non ti sia causa di ira
divina ma brucia mi con le armi tutte
quelle che ho e alza mi un tumulo in
riva al mare spumoso
duomo infelice in forma chi sarà compì
questo per me e sulla tomba pianta il
remo con il quale da vivo remava tra i
miei compagni possiamo quasi anche dire
che tutti forse siamo stati colpiti da
una perdita grave forse anche già l'anno
scorso quindi per via del fante della
pandemia ecco pensare anche che alla
morte di chi non c'è di coloro che ci
erano vicini che oggi non ci sono più
vicini sia proprio un ultimo viaggio per
mare no forse chissà è il peggiore
stanche chiedendo a odisseo di dargli un
remo per poter remare nell'aldilà
e poi tiresia questa bellissima profezia
ma quando i pretendenti nel tuo palazzo
avrai ucciso o con l'inganno o
apertamente con il bronzo acuto cioè con
le armi
allora partì prendendo il maneggevole
remo finché a uomini tu non giunga che
non conoscono mare ne mangiano cibo
mischiato col sale ne conoscono navi
dalle rosse guance né maneggevoli remi
che sono ali alle navi segno ti dirò
chiarissimo e non ti sfuggirà quando un
altro viandante incontrandoti ti dica
che ventilabro tieni sulla nobile spalla
allora piantato in terra il maneggevole
remo compiuti bay sacrifici per posidone
signore
ariete toro e porco a casa ritorna e
compì le sacre ecatombi high noon
immortali che il vasto c'è lo abitano a
tutti per ordine
ecco in brevissimo tempo che ho fatto
vedere come nasce una metafora che senso
può avere
che senso ha la lettera tu la domanda è
a che serve alla letteratura
la domanda da farsi invece come pensa la
letteratura come pensa la poesia come
pensa una parola grazie e buona serata a
tutti